-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
In a new interview
on "The View,"
Vice President Kamala Harris
said that the 2024 election
will come down to
"competence versus chaos."
Of course, if you're
watching "The View,"
you've already chosen chaos.
[ Laughter ]
In the same interview,
Harris criticized
presidential candidate
Nikki Haley's statement
that the US has never been
a racist country
and said, "We cannot get
to a place of progress
by denying
the existence of racism,"
but you can get to
the Republican nomination
for president.
President Biden traveled
to North Carolina today
and spoke about
his administration's
funding
for high-speed Internet,
which is why he's the only
candidate endorsed by Pornhub.
[ Laughter ]
In a post this week --
They were as surprised
as anyone.
[ Laughter ]
In a post this week
on Truth Social,
former President Trump
referred to Nikki Haley
using her given first name
of Nimarata and misspelled it,
though I bet no one noticed
that mistake on Truth Social.
They're still having a hard time
with "your" and "you're."
[ Laughter ]
During a rally last night
in New Hampshire,
former President Trump mocked
President Biden's competence
and asked the crowd,
"Would you trust
Joe Biden
to run your store
while you go off
to New Hampshire
to find a small hill
to go skiing?"
And the crowd responded
with a resounding, "What?
[ Laughter ]
Like, we're on your side, man,
but what?"
[ Laughter ]
Trump also complained
about his ongoing legal issues
and said, "You know, I've been
indicted more than Al Capone."
And I honestly can't tell
if he's bragging or complaining.
You know, old guys
reach a stage
where those things
sound the same.
"I got up at 5:30 this morning!"
"Okay. Good job. Sorry?
I don't know what you want."
And a new interview,
Microsoft co-founder Bill Gates
said that he's giving away money
at a rate of $9 billion a year,
and not one penny of it
to a barber.
[ Laughter ]
A state lawmaker in Kentucky
recently introduced a new bill
that would make it legal
for a person
to have sex
with a first cousin,
while Alabama
is making it mandatory.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I don't want to judge,
but that just
doesn't seem right.
A copy of the first issue of
"The Amazing Spider-Man" comic
was recently sold at auction
for $1.38 million.
Said the winner's wife --
[ Laughs ]
I'm kidding.
He doesn't have a wife.
[ Laughter ]
A production company announced
yesterday it's developing
a Chuck E. Cheese-themed
competition show
that will have adult contestants
try life-size versions
of classic arcade games,
like the one where you try
to eat enough pills
to get through
a kid's birthday party.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the restaurant
Applebee's has announced
that it will launch
a date night pass.
The way it works
is you say "date night"
and she says "pass."
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We are...up and running.